secretario general de Naciones Unidas
damas y caballeros jefes de estado y
gobiernos ministros Embajadores damas y
caballeros Es un honor para mí tomar la
palabra
para dar la voz de Francia y estoy
pensando ahora en aquellos que han
luchado por mi país pero también a lo
largo del mundo
el nombre de Francia en nombre de su
libertad
aquellas personas que pensaron que el
destino de Europa no podría ser
indiferente a ellos antes y aquellas
personas que vienen de África de Asia de
todo el mundo porque a través de el
ejercicio su libertad es lo que han
logrado
pienso en aquellas personas que han
escrito nuestra carta que han construido
los muros de esta organización
que han buscado detener Lo peor cuando
ha ocurrido dos veces en el siglo XX que
infligió sobre toda la humanidad un
sufrimiento inconmensurable por favor
nunca olvidemos que tenemos esa deuda
es esa en nuestros intereses de todos
nuestros pueblos nos muestra el poder de
la paz nos Recuerda
que no hay ninguna otra muestra este
tema de poder queduce tanto la
naturaleza distinta
a lo que los países deciden
soberanamente Y juntos eso dice que la
naturaleza Universal de nuestra
naturaleza de nuestra organización está
el servicio no está al servicio de
ninguna hegemonía no está al servicio de
ninguna jerarquía política
este legado
debes organización como nuestras
elecciones como nación
están siendo confrontados en estos
momentos por una alternativa
hoy necesitamos tomar una decisión
bastante simple básicamente
esa de la guerra o esa de la paz
en el 24 de febrero de este año Rusia o
miembro permanente del Consejo de
Seguridad a través de un acto de
agresión
lleva a cabo una agresión una anexión
esto rompió nuestra seguridad colectiva
y violó de Río Grande La carta de las
Naciones Unidas y el principio de
de soberanía igual entre Estados
del 16 desde el 16 de marzo de la Corte
Internacional de Justicia declaró la
agresión rusa como ilegal
y pidió el retiro de Rusia
Rusia decidió
pavimentar el camino para otras guerras
de anexión en Europa hoy y posiblemente
mañana en Asia o en África Incluso en
Latinoamérica
podemos decir cualquier cosa que
queramos hoy escucho muchas discusiones
muchas posturas que han sido tomadas y
hay algo muy claro muy cierto cuando
estoy hablando ustedes ahora y rusas hay
tropas rusas en Ucrania
y tanto como seno hay tropas ucranianas
en Rusia esa es una declaración y es un
hecho y todos necesitamos entender que
lo más que se alargue
esta guerra será peor más amenazante
para Europa y para el mundo eso nos
llevará un mayor conflicto un conflicto
en curso donde la seguridad de la
soberanía de todos ya no solamente
dependa de un balance de poder
o de la fuerza de las alianzas
sino
de la fuerza de grupos y milicias que se
consideran fuertes
que buscan sujetar subyugar a todos los
que consideren como débiles
algo que hemos visto desde el 24 de
febrero Un regreso a la vuelta Un
regreso a la era del imperialismo y de
la colonia algo que Francia rechaza
completamente Francia de manera
obstinada buscará por la paz nuestra
posición es Clara y queremos
servir ese propósito por eso es que
estoy entrando en diálogo con Rusia lo
hemos hecho desde el inicio de la guerra
hemos hecho esos últimos meses y seguiré
liderando este esfuerzo porque solamente
juntos que podemos encontrar la paz la
búsqueda por la paz con iniciativas que
son
asumidos o que han sido sumidas antes
del conflicto esa búsqueda de la paz que
viene desde el 24 de febrero por parte
de respaldo militar humanitario político
que le hemos brindado al pueblo
ucraniano para que ellos puedan
disfrutar de su derecho legítimo a la
defensa y a preservar su soberanía de la
lucha por la paz que lleva condenar la
invasión de un estado soberano y la
violación de nuestra seguridad colectiva
de nuestros principios los crímenes de
guerra cometidos por Rusia en Ucrania
y por nuestra negativa a ofrecer la
impunidad la justicia internacional debe
establecer los crímenes y condenar y
juzgar a los perpetradores la lucha por
la paz a través de nuestro derecho de
disminuir la expansionismo geográfico en
la guerra y aquí
estamos asumiendo la tarea de responder
los esfuerzos de la iaea para impedir el
impacto de la guerra
[Música]
en Plantas nucleares se asegurar su
eso trae la situación que pone en riesgo
país a Ucrania nos aseguraremos de que
la misión de la diaria fuera a Ucrania
de Establecer un reporte independiente
para prevenir el riesgo de un accidente
cuyas consecuencias puede hacer
devastadoras todos estamos al tanto hoy
aquí que solamente un acuerdo que
respete la ley internacional
permitirá que haya paz y permitir al
regreso de la paz
una negociación solamente puede ser
posible si de manera soberana o Ucrania
lo desea y Rusia lo acepta en buena fe
todos estamos al tanto
de que la negociación solamente
será exitosa
si Ucrania es soberana se le protege su
soberanía Rusia ahora debe
entender de beber que no pueden poner su
voluntad militariamente Incluso
si
una referendo pretencioso y falso en
territorios que han sido bombardeados y
ahora ocupados
depende de los miembros del Consejo de
Seguridad
decir esto en voz alta y Clara y a los
miembros de la asamblea respaldarnos en
Nuestro camino y esfuerzo por la paz
desde este podio le pido a los miembros
de las Naciones Unidas que actúen para
que Rusia rechace ese camino de la
guerra
y evalúe el costo para sí mismo y para
el resto de nosotros y realmente lleve
al final esta agresión estamos hablando
de elegir un campamento o un lado entre
el este y el oeste o entre el norte o el
sur lo que estamos diciendo es que es
responsabilidad de todos de cualquiera
comprometido el respeto a la carta
y a nuestro bien común más preciado que
es la paz porque Más allá de la guerra
hay un riesgo de dividir al mundo eso es
lo que está en riesgo y en juego acá
impactos directos indirectos de
conflicto Yo sé que aquí muchos
aprecian entienden esa sensación de
Justicia
por razones económicas energéticas y
otras consecuencias dramáticas
debido a la guerra conducida por Rusia
Yo sé que hay países aquí
que han elegido formar una que han
elegido la neutralidad
Honestamente hoy
quién
está diciendo claramente aquellos que
están diciendo que no están alineados
Están equivocados porque están tomando
una postura histórica es una era
el regreso del momento del momento no
alineados es un regreso a la lucha por
la paz a la soberanía de los estados en
nombre de la integridad territorial de
la lucha de los no alineados
aquellos que están manteniendo el
silencio hoy realmente están de alguna
manera siendo Cómplices con la causa de
una nuevo imperialismo
y un nuevo orden que está superando
montando encima del nuevo orden del
actual organismo no es posible acá Rusia
es hoy está hoy buscando mantener un
doble estándar pero la guerra en Ucrania
no debe ser un conflicto que deja
cualquier indiferente está bastante
cerca a los europeos que han respaldado
a Europa sin entrar a la guerra con
Rusia
está un poquito más distante algunos de
ustedes sin embargo todos están
sufriendo el impacto directo y todos
tenemos un rol para llevarla a su fin
porque todos estamos pagando el precio
por su propio cimiento de esta guerra
lanzada por Rusia está mirando el
principio de nuestra organización es
caminando
el único orden mundial posible
estaminando La Paz
la paz depende del respeto de la
intangibilidad de las fronteras y de las
Naciones soberanas con ese propósito no
perdamos aquí los esfuerzos quien aquí
puede defender la idea de que la
invasión de Ucrania
quién de aquí
de aquí puede considerar siquiera que el
día en el que algo similar ocurrió
con un vecino mucho más poderoso cuando
es el espacio ustedes quién podría
elegir el silencio
quién podría decir que esa es la mejor
solución que puede creer que Rusia
simplemente tiene que ganar esa cara
para que nosotros pasemos algo más nadie
podría querer eso el imperialismo
contemporáneo no es occidental no es
europeo toma la forma de una invasión
territorial vinculada con una guerra
híbrida modernizada que utiliza los
precios energéticos la seguridad
alimentaria la seguridad nuclear el
acceso a la información
movimientos de la población como armas
para obtener División y destrucción
ahí Es que la guerra
mina todas nuestras soberanía
Francia está del lado de los pueblos
libres de las Naciones Unidas para
lidiar las consecuencias del conflicto y
todas las inequidades al rechazar
estos estados mentales que consideran
bloques porque Más allá del impacto
directo de la Guerra el riesgo es
nuestro Hoy es el riesgo de una nueva
partición del mundo
algunos de nosotros algunas personas
quieren decir que hay un occidente que
defiende intereses desactualizados y que
hay un resto del mundo que ha sufrido
tanto que simplemente quiere cooperar
al mirar otro lado yo rechazo Esta
división por dos razones al menos en
primer lugar en principio y acabo de
mencionar esto nuestra organización
tiene valores universales
no nos permitamos
la sordera el hecho
o la ceguera ante la realidad regional o
que hay algo adaptable en la carta a
nuestra organización tiene valores
universales y la división
particularmente la guerra simple está a
favor de la ley del más fuerte el
irrespeto de la integridad territorial
de los países está a favor en contra de
la impunidad
yo no veo ningún tipo de orden
internacional ni Paz duradera que pueda
basarse
en el respeto a la responsabilidad no
veo ninguna opción distinta Ese es el
único orden nuestros valores son
universales y por eso es que no debemos
nunca servir un parador que viola a
Estos principios
en los últimos años cuando hemos asumido
la libertad con estos valores
hemos estado equivocados Pero
esto de ninguna manera puede justificar
acabar lo que hemos construido juntos
después de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
cuando escucho que Rusia dice que está
lista para trabajar en áreas de Nueva
cooperación con un nuevo orden
internacional sin ningún tipo de
hegemonía bueno
basados en que principios la invasión de
fronteras el respeto de las fronteras de
esos pueblos
Cuál es este orden Quién está jugando a
la hegemonía hoy es Rusia de qué estamos
hablando que están inventándose hoy
no hay nada no se puede sostener solo no
seamos ante el cinismo
que rechaza este orden que hemos
construido juntos y es lo único que
podemos sostener que puede permitirnos
sostener la estabilidad en el mundo el
respeto
por la fronteras el respeto
por la integridad territorial
estábamos equivocados cuando nos tomamos
libertades con esos valores después de
la Segunda Guerra Mundial después del
colonialismo
construimos algo distinto
dijimos que no que no íbamos a tener
esto de nuevo que no íbamos a aceptar
esa situación la segunda razón para mi
oposición es el intento de dividir de
partir el mundo es pragmática hay
divisiones recientes y mucho más allá
hay intentos de dividir el mundo de
exacerbar tensiones entre los Estados
Unidos y entre China
eso no puede convertirse en una nueva
guerra fría
hay muchos poderes diferentes que están
intentando
y promover tensiones regionales
y acabar con la seguridad colectiva y
promover el desarrollo atomizado creo
que debemos hacer todo lo posible para
asegurarnos que esta división no ocurra
porque
lo que enfrentamos ahora el desafío que
enfrentamos los desafíos son más
urgentes y requieren nuevas formas de
cooperación miremos a Pakistán por
ejemplo un tercio del país está bajo el
agua
muchas muchas personas han muerto
resultaron heridas el cuerno de África
la peor sequía en 40 años una temporada
lluviosa que se puede grabar después
media humanidad ya está viviendo en un
área de peligro climático nuestros
ecosistemas están llegando al punto de
no retorno
observemos somalia en yemen
del sur Afganistán la hambruna está
regresando
la crisis alimentaria está golpeando en
todas partes
y está afectando
a las personas más vulnerables
millones de niños están enfrentando la
hambruna
hay 100 millones de personas desplazadas
entre 1999 y 2015
solamente 130.000 personas pudieron
escapar de la pobreza y tantas personas
hoy están en países afectados por el
conflicto debido a estas crisis el
cambio climático la pandemia
el incremento en los precios de los
alimentos las personas más vulnerables
siempre son las peores afectadas las
amenazas siempre están ahí más allá de
todo eso está el terrorismo
que afecta el medio oriente la
proliferación nuclear en Irán y en Corea
del Norte también
no hemos logrado enfrentar esto
Esto es lo que Debemos enfrentar
urgentemente
y habían tantas descripciones que les he
dado esta lista no es exhaustiva todavía
pero cada vez que tenemos problemas en
nuestro sistema internacional
necesitamos
enfrentar esos problemas
muchos de esos problemas son causados
por divisiones entre nosotros por eso es
que es nuestra responsabilidad común y
compartida
debe ser ayudar a los más frágiles a
ayudar a los más vulnerables a lidiar
con estos desafíos nahindra el Primer
Ministro de la India estaba en lo
correcto cuando le dije cuando le dijo
no es momento para la guerra no es
momento para la venganza en contra del
occidente no es momento para oponer al
occidente contra el Oriente es momento
es un momento colectivo para nuestros
estados soberanos
para enfrentar esos desafíos por eso es
que hay una necesidad urgente de
desarrollar un nuevo contrato entre el
norte y el sur un contrato efectivo
que sea respetuoso de los alimentos
la educación
ya no es momento de pensar en bloques
sino de construir una coalición para una
acción específica de reconciliar a los
intereses legítimos
y el bien común ahora sobre la crisis
global alimentaria Francia duplicado su
contribución al programa Mundial de la
ONU sobre alimentación y tenemos correos
de solidar construidos para evacuar a
más de 10 millones de toneladas de grano
por tierra desde la primavera
Esto fue complementado usualmente por el
acuerdo en junio
gracias al trabajo del secretario
general de las Naciones Unidas
que permitió la evacuación de 2.4
millones de toneladas de grano a través
del mar Negro
tenemos la iniciativa de granjas esto
permite que los países vulnerables
que tengan inversiones agrícolas para
hacerse resilientes
también quisiera anunciar que
Francia
financiera la evacuación de grano
para Alianza con el programa Mundial de
la Alimentación estamos
ayudando solidariamente y efectivamente
Y tenemos un requerimiento de
transparencia completa mañana vamos a
encontrarnos con la unión africana los
agencias de las Naciones Unidas la
organización comercial mundial el fondo
monetario internacional el Banco Mundial
para desarrollar
el mecanismo que pueda asegurar acceso
al grano para África y respetaremos la
iniciativa del secretario general aquí
sobre el clima y la biodiversidad
en unas semanas estaremos en Egipto para
el 27 seamos claros Aquí también
Qué significa una transición justa
nuestro en nuestra primera lucha
colectiva es erradicar el carbón la
crisis no debe permitirnos perder vista
de esto si no lo hacemos
hercios
excederemos las predicciones de los
grados centígrados yo estoy listo para
invertir
en colisiones y financiarlas como hemos
hecho con Sudáfrica hace unos cuantos
meses y debemos continuar en esta lógica
pero China y los grandes poderes
emergentes deben tomar una decisión
Clara en este
eso es fundamental debemos
construir a partir de este trabajo y
junto con los poderes emergentes
colisiones estatales con instituciones
para construir soluciones completas para
la producción de energía y el cambio de
modelos de producción en la industria
sólo esto puede permitir tal transición
el g7 debe liderar con su ejemplo los
países más ricos deben acelerar sus
programas de natalidad carbono pero
también deben hacer un esfuerzo para
mejorar su comportamiento y compartir
tecnologías verdes en estas áreas se
puede contar con la Unión Europea y
ustedes lo saben
también creo que debemos reconocer que
para los países más pobres
hay una gran dificultad a la hora de
actuar tanto en contra de la pobreza y
en la velocidad de la transición no
podemos pedir lo mismo a la África
subsahariana con el 100 millones de
personas que todavía no tienen acceso a
la electricidad como podemos hacerlo con
Los Grandes emisores por eso es que la
solidaridad financiera la solidaridad
tecnológica entre los países más ricos
debe ser incrementada en términos de
clima para los países más podemos dar
financiamiento soluciones de
financiamiento y acelerar esta agenda
Cómo podamos durante la pandemia
Pero bueno debemos hacer esto de manera
más efectiva de una manera más resuelta
muy ese contexto también debemos juntos
proteger
[Música]
los precios de carbono y la
biodiversidad en Costa Rica en la
conferencia de las Naciones Unidas para
los océanos en 2025
tenemos que hacer que esto sea del cop
21 de los océanos sobre la salud
debemos aprender de la pandemia covid 19
lo hemos reconocer que nuestra primera
línea de defensa son los sistemas de
salud y los personales el personal de
salud en los países vulnerables voy a
Resaltar esto durante
la reunión del fondo mundial para
combatir la tuberculosis de la malaria
Francia seguirá siendo uno de los
principales contribuyentes también
debemos asegurarnos que la OMS
establezca sistemas de alerta temprana
para impedir la diseminación de otros
virus
y juntos lo hemos enfrentar los
problemas de salud humana y animal esto
es este es el propósito detrás de esta
salud iniciativa de salud que Francia
está liderando junto con otros países
como en el caso de la alianza mundial
por la educación tenemos que seguir
nuestros esfuerzos para que los niños
vayan a las escuelas después de la
pandemia la pandemia les quitó la
educación debemos luchar desde la fuente
en contra de cualquier tipo de equidad y
trabajar por nuestro futuro común como
han visto en todas las áreas tenemos
necesitamos más cooperación
debe haber alianzas entre el oeste y el
sur y el norte y el sur todo esto debe
ser desarrollado que cada vez mayores
compromisos entre ellos esas
instituciones todo esto es lo opuesto a
la división
quién durante la pandemia estuvo ahí
proponiendo financiamiento para la
transición climática
no son los que no están promoviendo en
el nuevo orden internacional
hasta que no tuvimos
vacunas funcionales no había solidaridad
no había contribución por el medio
ambiente en contra de todos esos
desafíos que son desafíos compartidos
tuvimos que actuar en Solidaridad
debemos cooperar más pero nunca
dejar espacio llamado de sirena que lo
llevan a ningún lado para lograr esto
También tenemos que ser lúcido sobre la
situación de los países más pobres y los
países de ingreso medio o sea en África
en el continente de sudamericano en Asia
o en el Pacífico
la pandemia ha incrementado la iniquidad
la guerra y sus consecuencias han
incrementado las dificultades para
muchos países el g20 debe
imperativamente mantenerse a su objetivo
del año pasado movilizar 100 mil
millones de dólares
de los permisos de extracción especial
pero debemos ir más allá
basados en estos derechos especiales de
explotación emitidos por el imf debemos
implementar lo que ya hemos comprometido
tantos países particularmente en África
no han visto este dinero
y no podemos explicarlos que hay un
parlamento bloqueando que hay una ley
que está impidiéndolo eso no puede
suceder estamos llegando demasiado tarde
pero tenemos que ir más allá porque las
dificultades son mayores
así debemos pasar de 30%
de la reubicación de los derechos de
extracción a los países africanos que
son los más pobres y a los países más
pobres en el resto del planeta y con el
Banco Mundial y el fondo monetario
internacional
debemos comprometer de nuevo nuestro
mecanismos
tiene que hacerse lo más apropiado para
el contexto sexual las reglas que hemos
aplicado hoy son las reglas de los 80
la situación de nuestro planeta después
del 19 con una mayor de regulación
climática y un mayor peligro por la
biodiversidad por los desbalances de la
guerra eso significa que necesitamos
mayor solidaridad debemos tener
un mayor compacto financiero con el sur
y ahí es donde debemos actuar
de eso debemos actuar juntos no en
contra de un enemigo común o en contra
de historias falsas o revisionismo
histórico sino En nombre del planeta que
vivimos y en nombre de la igualdad de
oportunidades son escala global esa
lucha es nuestra lucha lo que nos trae
juntos hoy
tenemos que hacer un poco más de
esfuerzo un poquito más ajustarnos a
nuestros acuerdos de ser exigentes y
respetuosos el uno con el otro
pero esta lucha Esta es la verdadera
lucha si no somos capaces de
enfrentarnos juntos será la fuente de
rupturas y conflictos en el futuro
Yo invito a todos aquellos que desean
construir este nuevo contrato con
nosotros a que vengan al Foro por la paz
de París el 11 de noviembre de este año
para preparar el g20 en Bali Y avancemos
juntos
sin rendirnos nunca en nuestros valores
comunes nuestros principios guía
debemos llegar al corazón de las cosas
no debemos ceder a la fragmentación del
mundo al incremento de amenazas a la paz
no debemos permitir
que las crisis se multipliquen
y que haya una proliferación de armas de
destrucción masiva son todos riesgos que
no podemos dominar en el futuro sí no
los enfrentamos si no enfrentamos a los
poderes que está más involucrados es
este trabajo involucrar poderes lo que
debemos hacer en el medio oriente
asegurarnos de seguimiento de la
conferencia 2019 biker para la
estabilidad de Irak o del Líbano de toda
la región
miembros del p5 ya no están solos en
lo que han dicho y si tienen algo que
decir y lo hacen eso solamente puede
funcionar si podemos trabajar de manera
más amplia hacia el concepto
internacional que es tan necesario para
la paz por eso es que espero que podamos
finalmente comprometernos a la reforma
del consejo de seguridad para que sea
mucho más representativo y de la
bienvenida nuevos miembros permanentes y
permanezca
y capaz de
ejercer
su poder y e impedir el uso de derecho
al veto en caso de crímenes masivos
juntos debemos construir paz
y el orden internacional contemporáneo
para que funcione bajo los objetivos de
nuestra carta
en ese camino las Naciones Unidas pueden
contar en cuestionablemente con Francia
en este camino cada país acá hoy
puede contar absolutamente con Francia
Muchas gracias